Voiceover: These are questions
from the Independent in the UK.
The first question is how does
he, I'm assuming that's me Sal,
how does he see the development
in video conferencing?
Particularly new services
like Google Hangouts
as affecting the provision
of distance learning.
Is that something that he sees
the Khan Academy using and
in what kind of time frame?
Interesting question, so
there's a couple of layers here.
First of all, just kind of
the idea of distance learning
and this is where I think right now
everything that's online learning
kind of gets grouped to into
distance learning and online learning
and all the same.
Most people kind of don't really
differentiate between what they are.
Right now, what's happening
with distance learning
is that they are for the most part
very similar what happens
in physical classes.
It's just the people
aren't in the same room.
Distance learning fundamentally,
they still involve
when someone is participating in the
learning there is a live professor
or teacher on the other side of that,
and they still are kind
of signing up for courses.
They still meet at a certain
time to do their courses
or to do their interactions.
I would call it much more in the
domain a synchronous learning
which means that all the parties
have to be there at the same time
and that all the students are also
kind of moving along at the same pace.
It really is exactly
as the physical model,
it's just they've taken the idea that
you have to be in the same place.
Khan Academy isn't the
only version of this
but Khan Academy, we kind of view
it as more of asynchronous model.
Asynchronous which really just means
that things aren't necessarily
happening at the same place.
Which is the idea that I can
record this video right now
and you don't have to be
listening to it right now.
You might listen to this video an hour
later or a day later, or a year later.
You can really go through
things at your own pace.
We don't view video conferencing as
maybe our main delivery mechanism
although distance learning,
vendors or companies or schools
might view video conferencing as
their main way to get to people.
We think, we can record videos, people
can consume those at their own pace
and we can give people
exercises and feedbacks
that they can do at their own pace.
Where we do think video
conferencing could be
really, really, really interesting, this
is something that we have not done yet.
We've kind of thrown around the idea
and we just really have to get
the bandwidth to address it,
is I think video conferencing
is an amazing way to have
peer to peer interactions.
Peer to peer, I'll just do the
acronym, peer to peer interactions.
Right now in a lot of the classrooms
that are piloting Khan Academy
or even the ones doing it on their own,
and this is what we really advocate
is every student works at their own pace
but when they're stuck either
this teacher intervenes
based on the data the teacher sees
or even better a student
intervenes and helps their peer.
There's no reason why that has to
be sit just in a physical classroom
but you can actually
transcend a physical classroom
and that's where something like video
conferencing could be really valuable.
If two people could share a blackboard
that looks very similar like this
and they have either a
tablet device or a pen tablet
like what I'm using right now, they can
run a tutoring session with each other.
Would even be cool if they could
record it and they could be archived
for other people to use it in the future.
That is really powerful and that's
mainly in the tutoring space,
so that you can have
peer to peer tutoring.
Tutoring or really
teaching or mentoring even.
The other interesting place where peer
to peer actions could be interesting,
I think this is completely untapped,
is the whole idea of assessment.
Right now, Khan Academy the
assessment piece happens,
you're doing exercises, it
keeps track of how you're doing.
In a traditional classroom assessments
are some form of paper exam.
It could be multiple choice, it could
be free answer, it could be essay exam
but I think what most of us have
always realized is that the most,
the highest form of assessment is
either the practical assessment
or the oral assessment.
Practical would literally mean
if you're studying to be a nurse
someone observes you while you're trying
to insert an IV into someones arm.
Oral examination, and this
is really the goal standard
for what we see in the academia.
Is when you're going to your qualifiers,
there's an oral part of that examination
and then essentially you'll sit in
front of a room full of faculty members
and they'll grill you on and make sure
you really, really, really do understand
a concept deeply.
What we think we could do, we're on the
peer to peer side is eventually have -
not only just a kind of assessment that
we already have in place of Khan Academy
but maybe an oral assessment.
Where right now maybe you are a,
we don't have the proper words for,
but maybe you are a level one in
Trigonometry or level one in Algebra
and you want to become
level two in Trigonometry.
You want to get into this,
like a smaller circle,
there's more a lead circle of people
who've gotten to this deep
level of trigonometry.
To do that, maybe at a
baseline you have to do some,
you have to show that you've
done something kind of
the traditional exercises
on Khan Academy at your own
pace and you've been able
to prove competency there.
But to really make it, then you
would have an oral examination
with maybe five people from level two.
If maybe four of the five say
that you are ready for level two
then you will be bumped up to level two.
Then one of your responsibilities
as someone in level two
is assess future people from
level one, coming from level one.
Then of course your next
aspiration is to go to level three
or going to become a
master of all of the Math
or whatever you might want to say.
I think peer to peer interactions
could be really, really powerful
when it comes to the assessment part.
I'd be hard pressed to see
how this isn't more rigorous
than really all the
assessment that has in place.
Because you're not just being
assessed by arbitrary peers,
you're being assessed by peers who've
already really proven themselves
to really deeply understand the concept.
The other things when you say,
is that something he sees the Khan
Academy using and what kind of time frame?
Once again we do see ourselves using
it but we don't know the time frame,
it's just a bandwidth issue.
That reminds me, so the other
area I think video conferencing
could be really powerful is in
the idea of foreign language.
Once again the goal standard in
foreign language is really immersion
but that's obviously not always
possible or economically possible.
The second best thing to immersion
is actually having live interactions
with people on the other side of the world
or maybe even not on the
other side of the world.
One thing I want to do with
my two and a half year old
is maybe get him a Skype or maybe
a Google+ buddy or whatever it is
in different countries so that
he can start chatting with kids
maybe his own age or little
older, little younger.
They can just start to at least get
the basics of each others languages
and start to teach each other.
I think it can have a lot to
be done, not full immersion
but some immersion for
foreign language learning.
Then a lot of the core
for the foreign language
like the vocabulary and the grammar, we
could probably do our exercise platform
but this is really what gives you
that deeper understanding of it.
The next question is, is
there a possibility of Khan
Academy's qualifications,
achievements being externally
validated at some point
such that they're
recognized internationally
as a measure of academic achievement?
There definitely is a possibility
and we are exploring to
see how can we validate
that when someone does
something on Khan Academy,
that it is really coming from them.
We think there are ways to do it.
We could even have places where you
could go and you could show your ID
or whatever and say,
"Hey look this is me."
"I'm not going to do
the Khan Academy there."
Then we could validate that yes this
was definitely the person who did that.
Then once you do that, we could
give badges or validations
that "Look this person really
does know that information."
Then it's a matter of making sure
that they are accepted broadly.
I think this actually touches
a generalized problem.
In that right now you and I have
talked about this in other videos,
in other lectures.
Right now education is kind of a
mixture of you have the learning part,
you have the credentialing part,
and then you have a little
bit of a socialization part.
You have a little bit of socialization.
When you go to a university
and you pay the big tuition
you're kind of getting all of these
stuff and depending who you ask,
different people think they're paying
for or providing different things.
If you ask most students
at most universities,
they're probably most
focused on the credential.
But if you ask most of the universities
they'll say, "Hey no, all of our resources
are going to this right over here."
"The credential is just to make sure
that people are learning the things,"
"but actually spending
the resources over here."
That question I think about whether
Khan Academy can get credentials,
so frankly where the third
party can get credentials
I think is just the whole
issue of can we decouple this?
Can we separate, can we
create a line of separation
between the learning side of
education and the credentialing side?
I think if you do that generally
something really powerful happens.
If we can create, and it doesn't
have to come from Khan Academy.
It can come from a government,
it can come from NGOs,
it can come from who
knows where it comes from.
If there is an internationally recognized
battery of examinations, assessments
and deep assessments they can
be practical, they can be oral,
they can be paper based, all of the above.
If you have something like this
that is internationally recognized
then all of a sudden the
rest of the education world
will compete right over here
and then there students will just try
to get this thing right over here.
What's exciting about something like that
is then Khan Academy could
compete on equal footing.
Because if students who choose to
go through Khan academy for free,
perform just as well on that as a student
who's spending tens of
thousands of dollars
or maybe certain students who say, "We
know this just works better for me."
Or maybe some students
will just learn on the job
or they'll learn from textbooks
but allows students to
learn the best way they can,
the best way that fits their career
and even their economic situation.
The other good thing is, this
is internationally recognized
it solves the problem that right
now there are some big name schools
that if you're lucky enough
to attend one of those schools
you do have something on your resume
that anywhere in the world
or anywhere in the country
someone might recognize it.
The problem is most universities
aren't internationally recognized
or aren't recognized
broadly beyond one region,
and so you have students who are doing
this really, really well right now.
They're learning or they're
potentially learning really well
maybe at their regional university
or their community college
and then they get this credential.
Then they get this
credential right over here
but this credential is not
universally recognized.
It's not the goal of the neighboring
state or the neighboring country
and people don't know how
to assess that credential.
This way those students who really
do learn their material well
will be able to take this
external assessments and prove
that they know just as well as the
student who went to Oxford or Harvard.